so in the last couple videos i talked
about partial derivatives of
multivariable functions and here i want
to talk about second partial derivatives
so i'm going to write some kind of
multivariable function let's say it's
i don't know sine of x times y squared
sine of x multiplied by y squared
and if you take the partial derivative
you have two options given that there's
two variables you can go one way and say
what's the partial derivative partial
derivative of f with respect to x
and what you do for that
x looks like a variable as far as this
direction is concerned y looks like a
constant so we differentiate this by
saying
the derivative of sine of x is cosine x
you know you're differentiating with
respect to x and then that looks like
it's multiplied by a constant so you
just continue multiplying that by a
constant
but you could also go another direction
you could also say
you know what's the partial derivative
with respect to y
and in that case you're considering y to
be the variable so here it looks at y
and says y squared looks like a variable
x looks like a constant sine of x then
just looks like sine of a constant which
is a constant so that'll be
that constant sine of x
multiplied by the derivative of y
squared which is going to be 2 times y
2 times y
and these these are what you might call
first partial derivatives and there's
some alternate notation here
d f d y you could also say f and then a
little subscript y and over here
similarly you'd say f with a little
subscript x
now each of these two functions these
two partial derivatives that you get are
also multivariable functions they take
in two variables and they output a
scalar so we can do something very
similar where here you might then apply
the partial derivative with respect to x
to that partial derivative
of your original function with respect
to x right
it's it's just like a second derivative
in ordinary calculus but this time we're
doing it partial so when you do it with
respect to x
cosine x looks like cosine of a variable
the derivative of which is negative sine
times that variable
and y squared here just looks like a
constant so it just stays constant at y
squared
and similarly you could go down a
different branch of options here and say
what if you did your partial derivative
with respect to y
of that whole function which itself is a
partial derivative with respect to x
and if you did that
then um
y
y squared now looks like the variable so
you're going to take the derivative of
that which is 2y
y
and then what's in front of it just
looks like a constant as far as as far
as the variable y is concerned so that
stays as cosine of x
and the notation here first of all just
as in single variable calculus it's
common to kind of do a
abusive notation with this kind of thing
and write partial squared
of f
divided by
partial x
squared
and this always i don't know when i when
i first learned about these things they
always threw me off because here this
leibniz notation you have the great
intuition of you know nudging the x and
nudging the f but you kind of lose that
when you do this but it makes sense if
you think of this partial partial x as
being an operator and you're just
applying it twice
and over here the way that that would
look it's a little bit funny because you
still have that partial squared f on top
but then on the bottom you write partial
y
partial x
and you know i'm putting them in these
order just because it's as if i i wrote
it that way right this reflects the fact
that first i did the x derivative then i
did the y derivative
and you could do this on this side also
and this might feel tedious but it's
actually actually kind of worth doing
for a result that we end up seeing here
that
that i find a little bit surprising
actually
so here if we go down the path of doing
in this case like a partial derivative
with respect to x
and you know you're thinking of this as
being applied to your original partial
derivative with respect to y
it looks here it says sine of x looks
like a variable 2y looks like a constant
so what we end up getting is derivative
of sine of x cosine x
multiplied by that 2y
and
a pretty cool thing worth pointing out
here that maybe you take it for granted
maybe you think it's as surprising as i
did when i first saw it both of these
turn out to be equal right even though
it was a very different way that we got
there right you first take the partial
derivative with respect to x and you get
cosine xy squared which looks very
different from sine x2y
and then when you take the derivative
with respect to y um
you know you get a certain value and
when you go down the other path you also
get that same value and maybe the way
that you'd write this is that you'd say
let me just
copy this guy over here
and what you might say is that
the partial derivative of f when you do
it the other way around when instead of
doing x and then y you do
y
and then x
partial x
that these guys are equal to each other
and that's a pretty pretty cool result
and maybe in this case given that the
original function just looks like the
product of two things you can kind of
reason through why it's the case but
what's surprising is that this turns out
to be true
for i mean not all functions there's
actually a certain a certain criterion
there's a special theorem it's called
schwarz schwartz's theorem
where
if the second partial derivatives of
your function are continuous at the
relevant point that's the circumstance
for this being true but for all intents
and purposes the kind of functions you
can expect to run into
this is the case this
order of partial derivatives doesn't
matter truth turns out to hold which is
actually pretty cool and i'd encourage
you to play around with some other
functions just come up with any
multi-variable function maybe a little
bit more complicated than just
multiplying two separate things there
and see that it's true and maybe try to
convince yourself why it's true in
certain cases i think that would
actually be a really good exercise
and just before i go one thing i should
probably mention a bit of notation that
that people will commonly use uh with
this second partial derivative sometimes
instead of saying partial squared f
partial x squared they'll just write it
as partial and then x x and over here
this would be partial let's see first
you did it with x then y so over here
you do it first x and then y kind of the
order of these reverses because you're
reading left to right but when you do it
with this you're kind of reading right
to left for how you multiply it in
which would mean that this guy let's see
this guy over here you know he would be
partial first you did the y
and then you did the x so those two
those two guys
are just different notations for the
same thing i mean that can make it a
little bit more convenient when you
don't want to
write out the entire partial squared f
divided by partial x squared or
things like that
um
and with that i'll call it an end